our first guest was born right here in
brooklyn and yet he just joined the la
lakers so it sounds like we're switching
places
um because i'm from california i don't
know if you can tell by my accent um he
is one of the
greatest nba players of all time he's a
10-time nba all-star and a four-time
olympian but his journey to the top
wasn't easy
um he has a new memoir out it's titled
where tomorrows aren't promised
and it gives readers a very real look
into the obstacles that he faced and the
odds he had to beat so please welcome
carmelo anthony
thank you so much
[Applause]
i'm feeling a very velour on velour
velvety vibe going on with your four
four you gotta tap into the fall season
now i love it you look so good thank you
thank you um
you just signed a one-year contract with
the l.a lakers
and obviously i'm going to get into the
old friend lebron of it all but why did
you make that choice may i ask
i almost got forced to do it
okay almost got four i think lebron
forced me to do it
okay he he waited to the right time he
waited to you know we at the end of our
careers
and
he said the time is now
if you don't do it now we ain't gonna
never do it and
we're both going into our 19th season i
mean that's that's very there's not too
many people that can say that and and
still at that at the top of the game and
still doing it at a high level so
you know early on i don't think it would
have worked out between us because he
was on his path i was on my path we had
we had different lanes i just think
everything happens
for a reason you know and timing is
everything i'm so in love with the title
of your book because it has so many
overarching themes of life i work every
day because i know that most of the jobs
that i've had in life are gonna end they
are not permanent um
i know that if i don't work my butt off
there probably won't be a tomorrow and
that's my work ethic
what is it for you
that incentivizes you
understanding that tomorrow's on promise
and understanding
i'm i come from where tomorrow's on
promise and i really just wanted to tell
that story of actually where
the true essence of where tomorrow's on
promise i mean those environments
there's no promise and there's no hope
in those environments why did you decide
to share that now in this book
i think now where i'm at in just my life
and just my career it's a sense of
discovery like trying to figure out
who you know who i am who who truly
who's the true essence of of carmelo
anthony and in that discovery
i came to write that book because for so
long i had that those stories and that
information
kind of just and i tucked in the closet
somewhere i didn't want that story i
didn't want that feeling and to relive
those stories so
i'm i decided you know i'm going to try
to be vulnerable i'm going to try to
open up i'm allow myself to let people
uh in into my world but into that world
because that's a totally different world
than
my my career that's the prequel to to my
career the origin story absolutely i uh
when i wrote a book um
i realized writing it that when i spoke
about my mom who and i i've been through
so much tough stuff with her um
i just had nothing but like
dignity
grace appreciation
objectivity i wasn't coming at this as a
wounded child
and i realized that i i had
gotten over certain
guilts and resentments and just that i
was a different person that i than i was
when i was a kid and had i not written
this book i
i couldn't believe like how much grace
and appreciation i had for things
i i felt that
kind of speaking about my mom because me
and my mom we have a great relationship
but we've never sat and had like a real
real real true conversation
about the upbringing
and
it took until
just recently right probably before i
started writing the book i sat with her
and we were just telling stories and she
told me she's like baby look
you need to get your story out there so
once she blessed it it was like i'm okay
i'm good i'm good i'm free i was free
i was free because it was it's a lot of
stories and i speak on my stepdad in
there too
and for so long i kind of just put a lid
on that and i didn't want to touch that
at all and nobody nobody knew that even
my mom didn't know a lot of those
stories
i feel like i am feeling a true shift in
our world that because athletes are
coming out and talking about their past
their spirits their heads their hearts
their bodies their brains
think athletes like we we're we're
naturally depressed
being an athlete i mean what we have to
go through on a day-to-day basis dealing
with media competing at the highest
level
we spend more time with our teammates
than we do with our family during the
year so
you miss holidays and it's and so on and
so forth so it's a lot of things that
you know the average person don't really
understand that an athlete have to go
through so it wasn't until i started
actually writing a book and going
through that process where i was able to
kind of get it the real true meaning of
kind of who i am and putting everything
into perspective taking a step back you
have to
you have to and i've realized from a
lifetime of
holidays with no family holidays with
friends holidays with my children now
how to co-parent how to be a parent how
to be a child looking at your parents
that i now tattooed home is where we are
yes because in an uprooted inconsistent
life you just got to say wherever
we're connected is that's home today
absolutely
and um
i love you i appreciate it i love you
too i don't mean to be creepy but
i
i just believe in everything you're
saying and i'm hanging on your every
word
[Music]